voilà pour ce portrait de silvio
berlusconi signé anne veron et gharbi
avec nous ce soir emmanuel dolce bonsoir
vous êtes membre du parti démocrate
italien merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés christian delporte
bonsoir vous êtes professeur à
l'université de versailles et historien
des médias
à ma gauche alberto toscano bonsoir vous
êtes journaliste et écrivain italien et
enfin marc lazar vous êtes historien
sociologue spécialiste de la vie
politique italienne professeur a lieu
paix de paris bienvenue à tous alors
d'abord vos réactions à ce documentaire
ce que vous en avez pensé est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pas d'accord donc des
intérêts saint bien fait elle pas de
pause les problèmes de jouer en italie
berlusconi l'italie à mon sens c'est
aujourd'hui à une période un tournant
réellement un tournant historique
de là il ya eu des tournants de la
première seconde république 94
aujourd'hui on est en train de passer de
la 2d de notre deuxième république
on ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'une heure
troisième république doit être mais le
déclin berlusconien qui est très bien
résumé exprimés dans ce film est une
chose désormais incontestable je crois
que c'est un documentaire très
pédagogique qui rien montre à la fois
l'ascension l'apogée et puis
effectivement le déclin cible d'un
scanner on peut discuter sur deux trois
petits points de détail ce qui est très
intéressant c'est les témoignages ou en
tout cas les interventions eric joseph
qui est le correspondant de libération
restitue sa dans une perspective
historique je crois qu'il le fait bien
il ya des interventions très intéressant
de proche de silvio berlusconi marcello
des loteries un homme clé qui racontent
beaucoup de choses intéressantes sur la
psychologie du personnage son côté
battant et qu'on va retrouver même dans
la situation actuelle
et puis carlo fred shero qui a été
l'homme qui a conçu la télévision
berlusconienne situationniste au départ
berlusconi ensuite qui va rompre avec
lui qui travaillera d'ailleurs en france
avec france télévisions et qui est sans
doute l'un des meilleurs analystes de la
télé j'ai travaillé en force comme
directeur de l'asa qui ensuite aux côtés
de jean pierre elkabbach à france
télévisions et canal pas aussi je dirais
que le documentaire est intéressant mais
il ya beaucoup d'image que les français
ne connaissais pas avant tout ça
s'adresse à un public français
on voit bien comment d'une manière ou
d'une autre qu'il était au pouvoir qu'il
était dans l'opposition berlusconi a
marqué 20 ans de la vie politique
italienne
autrement dit une génération l'italien
bon une page est peut-être tourner mais
en tout cas ce que mental est
intéressant là évidemment on pourrait
toujours dire ils manquent tel ou tel
chose on en repart à peut-être les
relations avec avec mitterrand peut-être
des aspects liés à l'imaginaire
berlusconien qui est donc tout à fait
fondamentale pour comprendre le
phénomène
je trouve qu'elle est un documentaire
est très était très bien fait et je
trouve surtout que bien que en étant
italia bien sûr je connais l'histoire
italienne rai compté pour elle
l'histoire de berlusconi notamment je
pense que la plupart des italiens
aimerait avoir une reconstruction aussi
bien fait de l'histoire de berlusconi
descend de son parcours parce que tout
le monde connaît berlusconi finalement
nice et lille mais pas forcément dans
cette perspective qu est que l'on voit
mieux construire dans les dents car
l'aspect s'est pressée de esther bien
fait je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
même une petite table et c'est à dire
qu'ils ont dit que le parti communiste
était le seul parti politique italienne
n'avait pas avoir été touché par
inquiète nos propres j'aimerais bien que
ce soit vrai mais ce ne l'est pas il a
eu
primo gregan vie en prison qui était
l'un des argentières des protagonistes
il ya eu d'autres condamnations de
raquette mains propres ceci dit il est
évident qu'il est évident que la gauche
italienne et un particulier le parti
communiste a été beaucoup moins touché
que le centre la droite
j'ai juste une chose je conteste pour
question de prudence
l'idée que berlusconi soit finie connaît
effectivement en train de tourner une
page parce que j'avais 14 ans 1994 que
berlusconi pris le pouvoir et déjà lors
de la première enquête sur mon dos
connaît tout le monde animaux ce
principe dans le ski c'est fini c'est
sûr que c'est fini l'a entretemps j'ai
eu le temps de faire mes études de me
marier divorcer même est en train de se
dire toujours là c'est quand même donc
méfiance je suis
justement est-ce que c'est fini ou pas
en tout cas c'est une première mercredi
27 novembre
silvio berlusconi a donc été déchu de
son poste de sénateur suite à une
condamnation à un an de prison pour
fraude fiscale
c'est un symbole qu'est ce qu'il faut
voir à travers cette sanction
c'est sûr que c'est un moment crucial
dans sa propre carrière c'est une étape
de nouvelles dans son déclin c'est
incontestable il est privé maintenant du
mandat parlementaire il n'a plus
d'immunité il peut être d'ailleurs
menacé encore plus par les juges et
certains vont s'obstiner contre lui avec
de bonnes raisons d'ailleurs parce qu'il
a plusieurs affaires il va plus être
peut-être qu'il sera même privé de
possibilités de communication son
discours du mercredi 27 devant chez lui
il n'était pas au sénat alors que les
sénateurs étaient assez emblématique
parce que c'est un discours où il
n'arrêtait pas dire qu'il était toujours
là et pourquoi il dit ça parce que et ça
c'est un lien avec le documentaire que
ce n'était pas assez souligné
il sait très bien ce qui est arrivé à
celui qui doit protéger pendant des
années pour rétablir sa télévision c'est
à dire bettino craxi le socialiste
italien qui avait dû partir d'ailleurs
on le voit si je me suis la mère dans le
documentaire sous une volée de deux
petites pièces de monnaie qui s'était
réfugié à hammamet en tunisie ce qu'a
voulu dire hier berlusconi christian
delporte parler du pouvoir de l'image
c'était je reste là je continue il était
accroché à son pupitre pour dire je
serai toujours là comment va-t-il être
toujours là ça va être son grand
problème ne pas aller en prison pas
normalement il peut
moi je vois pas comme quelque chose de
probables il ya une hantise la presse
qu'il dit on joue beaucoup
normalement il ne peut pas aller en
prison pour la peine qui lui a valu la
levée de l'immunité parlementaire parce
qu'il a plus de 70 ans mais ce qu'il
craint alors peut-être qu'il entretien
express est crainte ça fait peur et
petit son jeu de communication d'image
de se présenter comme une victime de
cette magistrature communiste mélodies
son obsession c'est son obsession c'est
d'être mise en détention préventive
parce que pour d'autres affaires les
juges italiens peuvent utiliser des
procédures de la loi qui par exemple 10
6-1 inculpés ou une personne qui est
poursuivi par la justice peut partir à
l'étranger on peut l'arrêter ça peut pas
être le cas de berlusconi parce qu'on a
même retiré son passeport mais si on
suspecte quelqu'un de pouvoir
éventuellement intervenir dans la sphère
en cours et d'exercer des pressions
voire de modifier les preuves on peut le
mettre en détention préventive par
exemple quand vladimir poutine peut
éventuellement lui donner un passeport
diplomatique et c'est pas possible
et ça ne le fera pas il le fera pas il
n'acceptera jamais mais ça me parait
t'il mais c'est ce qui distrait jamais
dit je suis jamais mêlé l'italie je suis
italien et sa hantise mais encore une
fois est-ce que c'est un jeu politique
ou pas c est ce que demain les
carabiniers vont arriver chez moi et me
dire on le tenait en détention
préventive parce qu'il ya telle affaire
voilà ce qu'il en joue les mails
certains maïs tran dinh en est pas
question
ses avocats ont joué beaucoup il faut
savoir faut le reconnaître qu' il ya une
guerre entre berlusconi et la
magistrature comme il ya une guerre
entre toute la classe politique et la
magistrature en italique certains
magistrats
encore une fois s'appuyant sur des vrais
faits ont envie de pendre haut et court
berlusconi en place quête d'un terrain
d'ailleurs à la l'évolution on ne
viendra plus tard je crois que
maintenant qu'on va voir
la puissance ou pas de lempire d'als
commis en matière de médias en matière
de communication la télévision la presse
aussi moi j'ai été très frappé mercredi
soir au soir du la déchéance de
berlusconi que lorsqu'on allait sur la
page d'accueil il giornale
c'est un son journal on était accueilli
par une page en sept langues avec fin de
la liberté
et quand on est allé un petit peu plus
loin c'était la démocratie détruite je
crois que c'est ce thème là le thème de
la victimisation qu'il va nourrir
il avait des partisans nombreux arrivés
en car pour le soutenir il a fait un
show extraordinaire
au soir de cette déchéance il faut voir
jusqu'où ce cette tension peut continuer
ceci dit le pouvoir de berlusconi d'un
la communication en général
aujourd'hui est inférieur par rapport à
il ya quelques années et en particulier
son point fort c'est évidemment la télé
et dans le secteur de la télévision
jouer autrefois il y avait six chaînes
3d la rai 3 privé de mediaset et
berlusconi en tant que président du
conseil avait un droit de regard et bien
plus que des grèves aussi sur la rai en
plus que sur ses propres chaînes
aujourd'hui en italie il ya quand même
la cet qui fait de la formation très
dynamique
la rai a fait des pas en avant important
important et bien cette je vais mal
alors il ya que le jeu soit sincèrement
ce serait triste jeu sur le fait que
certains émission de la rai combat les
rares soit des émissions indépendante
j'aurais du mal c'était
ça ne m'a pas et il ya d'autres chaînes
qui se sont développées et sky et
d'autres chaînes privées qui sont qui
ont un poids dans aujourd hui merlos
comme dans le secteur de la
communication ne pèse plus ce qui pesait
il ya des 1 voir que tant qu'elle est
agréé le clan berlusconi le parti alors
il s'est scindée en deux temps c'est
fondamental il ya une rupture au sein de
du camp berlusconi le peuple de la
liberté son parti a explosé il a
reconstitué forza italia d'où les
photographies et les images du meeting
de mercredi 1 on voit les drapeaux de
nouveaux qui sont ressortis de forza
italia une partie de ses propres amis et
notamment celui qui l'avait désigné
comme étant son successeur alfano qui
ministre actuellement à fonder est en
train de fonder un autre parti qu'ils va
s'appeler le nouveau centre droit avec
différents ministres un bon qu'elle quel
va être l'avenir de ce parti ça ça va
être une grande question
les anciens ex fascisme est vraiment
excellent ex fesci sont repartis de leur
côté donc le centre droit est totalement
éclatés c'est un de ces grands problèmes
et lui il a besoin d'affirmer qu'il est
le leader mais dans un panorama du
centre-droit éclaté et avec elle son
affaiblissement puisqu'il ne peut plus
directement être candidat et aussi il
faut le dire aussi c'est un homme un peu
usés
alberto rappeler qu'il a le moins
d'emprise médiatique il a quand même une
page et les 36 dans le temps passe tout
le mois vous êtes d'accord
enfin vous vous disiez moi je me
méfierais toujours enfin là les
conditions sereines très différentes
les conditions sont certainement terre
très différente par rapport à 1 par
rapport à quelques années après dans la
politique en démocratie c'est ce qui
compte cent des votes
donc il va falloir voir déjà le résultat
des élections européennes
parce que les élections européennes il y
aura les parti de berlusconi et le
nouveau centre droite de qui vont se
mesurer parce qu'elle est c'est un
système proportionnel donc bon
effectivement compter lors de l'un de
l'autre
mon impression est qu'il donne jusqu'en
y aura quand même bien plus de votes que
les centres le nouveau centre droite et
on verra monument l'impressionnent n'est
pas aussi clair que les nouveaux
centraux droite se séparer des
mollusques unis ça peut être un jeu qui
joue pendant quelques mois et après se
rassemblent à nouveau en vue de
prochaines élections politiques de toute
façon je vois pas d'autre possibilité
pour les autres à suivre alors quand on
regarde ce documentaire il ya quand même
un certain nombre de questions de zones
d'ombré si qui demeurent et notamment
sur la personnalité réelle de berlusconi
on entend certains dire c'est un
imbécile c'est l'ignorance tard et alors
il ya quelque chose d'assez frappant
parce qu'on se dit mais comment dire de
quelqu'un que c'est un imbécile ou en
ignorant alors qu'il a été élu plusieurs
fois à la tête d'un pays à l'autre il
est tout sauf un imbécile et supplée il
faut dire que d'un regarde les saints
des derniers jours
il ya là comme un côté tragi comique de
ce tome de ses fins c'est un nom qui
possède 5 ou 6 milliards d'euros
il a 60 élus va avoir 60 18 ans il
pourrait parfaitement se payer tout ce
qu'il désire
je n'entre pas dans les détails mais
hélas il reste accroché à cette
tentative de revanche de vengeance il y
a un côté qui n'est pas rationnelle et
qui est réellement tragi-comique comique
il est évident parce que c'est un homme
qui évidemment a commis des fautes et il
laissait d'affirmer qu'il est
parfaitement un ordre avec la justice la
loi et qui refusent sont des communistes
qui veulent le limogés et dans la
vieillesse de cet homme il y à tout ce
côté un sable et un jour quelqu'un
écrira une histoire un roman sur le
dernier qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce
qu'il cherche à travers à travers tout
ça il a fait un prêt demeure il en fait
un point d'honneur et cherche à vous
maintenant évidemment ils cherchaient
pas aller en prison mais il cherche une
revanche politique qui ne viendra qui
n'aura pas parce que l'italie est sur le
plan est en train d'avoir une
recomposition politique et de force très
puissante qui s'appelle vatican qui
s'appelle un gala merck qui s'appelle le
patronat italien tout s'assemble pouces
pour un message de démocrates d'une
nouvelle démocratie chrétienne et
berlusconi et son parti risque d'être
marginalisé sur la droite et l'italie va
vers probablement à centre gauche
j'espère que la gauche italienne aura
plus de choses à dire que la simple
critique du berlusconisme accra parce
que les problèmes des pays mais ne
change pas merci berlusconi parce que la
personnalité de balkany a été
sous-estimé en france oui
je pense qu'il est tout effectivement je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec alberto
il est tout sauf un imbécile
c'est au contraire quelqu'un dont le
parti la gauche italienne
la gauche a commis deux erreurs par
rapport à 6 mai au valjoly d'après moi
la première c'est de sous-estimer silvio
berlusconi dans un premier temps pensant
que c'était un épiphénomène ça c'est en
1994 on le voit bien dans le
documentaire ce qu'un accès de fièvre
comme ça dans un moment très compliqué
de l'effondrement des partis politiques
du système politique qu'au bout de sept
mois on le voit bien il est obligé
d'abandonner le pouvoir est vraiment
toute la gauche est convaincu que c'est
ça on allait revenir à une situation
normale
ou alors de le surestimer de diaboliser
silvio berlusconi et de ne pas essayer
de comprendre la profondeur de ce qu'il
représente et dont on parlera à clé
pourquoi un certain nombre d'italiens
pas comme on dit en france tous les
italiens mais pour aller vite moitié des
italiens 6 reconnu un moment donné dans
berlusconi pour des raisons très
différentes d'ailleurs mais ça c'est une
chose puis de l'autre côté yahia
berlusconi qui a pour différentes
raisons s'est lancé en politique
d'ailleurs le documentaire explore
différentes hypothèses ses affaires ses
propres affaires sa dimension aussi de
un peu de mégalomanie pensant qu'à un
moment donné il était le sauveur il
pouvait être le sauveur de la patrie le
fait qu'un certain nombre
d'intellectuels faut jamais oublier qu'à
des grands intellectuels consulte lui
silvio berlusconi il faut arrêter de
penser qu'il était entouré de débiles
mentaux
il est entouré de gens il ya des grands
constitutionnalistes des juristes des
historiens des collègues qui ont ceux
des journalistes de talent qui ont
soutenu silvio berlusconi qui ont dit tu
peux être l'homme qui va sortir l'italie
de la station où elle est et la
moderniser à la fois du point de vue de
la communication politique mais
christian peut en parler beaucoup mieux
que moi
du point de vue de l'organisation
politique et même il faut jamais oublier
en 94 il se présente comme un libéral
sur comme quelqu'un qui va libéraliser
l'économie et la société italienne
il a compris quelque chose important
dans notre époque c'est que la politique
c'est pas de la rationalité
la politique c'est d'abord un imaginaire
et il a construit cet imaginaire il est
le constructeur de son propre mythe
il est fantastique concepteurs de
storytelling
je vais il suffit de voir dans la
campagne de 2001 il
diffuse son parti diffuse une brochure
sur papier glacé on voyait à tous les
italiens qui s'appelle une histoire
italienne où il raconte sa propre
histoire où il raconte en fait ma propre
histoire c'est la vôtre
voilà je suis un petit italien avec une
famille normale et puis je suis devenu
un self made man qui a réussi et
regardez comme j'ai réussi c'est ça
c'est d'avoir comme il ya dix ans je
suis comme vous oui mais il faut bien
comprendre que depuis 1945
on cherche les leaders en italie et il
émerge comme un leader
autrement dit comme quelqu'un auxquels
on peut s'identifier avec cette
particularité c'est que il ne voit pas
les cils et les italiens seulement comme
des citoyens comme des consommateurs de
politique et il bâtit au niveau de
l'italie et de sa démarche politique
ceux qui la font pour l'entreprise et
donc quand il se lance en politique en
il a une certaine vision cercle il
comprend en gros que les italiens ou cas
une grande partie des italiens ont perdu
confiance en la classe politique et donc
il va construire et adapter un discours
de publicitaire presque destiné et c'est
ça qui va lui permettre d'entrer en
politique
oui ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
c'est cette liaison entre ce qu'il donne
sur les scènes publiques
et puis ces télévisions viol et
l'imaginaire de spectacles de la
télévision c'est ce qu'on va retrouver
en politique il fait du spectacle
politique comme il fait du spectacle
télévisé il le considère ça c'est
intéressant à mes lentilles a construit
ccc différentes télévisions maintenant
sympa sa part assez assez banal mais à
l'époque il construit les chaînes qui
correspondent à des secteurs
sociologique de la population que c'est
plutôt en avance sur son temps c'est là
dans les années 80 90 s étant sous la
révolution la télévision mais il faut
distinguer deux je pense de choses
excusez moi pour aller dans le sens de
christian il est complété d'un côté
l'équation personnelle de silvio
berlusconi l'homme la personnalité son
style son son charisme c'est cette
incroyable capacité qu'il a de
contacté les gens de parler avec les
gens de on le sait on a des multiples
exemples qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas tous
dans le documentaire c'est normal mais
bon quiconque l'a rencontré le le voit
enfin il y avait une sorte de magnétisme
il ya il y avait une sorte de magnétisme
berlusconi dans un pays est
effectivement ou jusqu'ici serre
jusqu'en 94 la politique est faite par
des partis politiques et où on a peu de
communication politique fait partie
était habitué à parler à leurs électeurs
n'y avait pas beaucoup de changements et
là tout s'écroule et donc il ya des
électeurs qu'il faut conquérir et
séduire ça c'est l'équation personnelle
berlusconi il ya autour de lui
sapho on ne dit pas assez en france il
ya tout un des gens très différents qui
ont des projets qu'ils proposaient
berlusconi lui après il va prendre les
libéraux lui propose de faire comme
margaret thatcher ou ronald reagan il
prend cette idée là les traditionalistes
catholiques qui sont dans son côté lui
dit il faut que tu défendre l'église est
d'ailleurs très bien je vais défendre
l'église
il ya des conservateurs autour de lui il
ya des pro européens il ya des anti
européens et c'est des gens qui ont on
le sait maintenant qu'ils ont
brain-storming qui ont travaillé pour
lui avant sa prise de pouls s avança
indécente en politique comme il dit
utilisant la métaphore du football un
très important mais un évidemment et il
va bricoler tout ça autour de sa
personne mais ça je me permets de
rajouter c'est un nom pour lesquels les
valeurs ne compte rien d' une amoralité
absolue il choisit ce qui l'intéresse il
entre en politique parce que son groupe
est endetté et il craque dans le cadre
d'un gouvernement de gauche
son groupe de tous payaient les bars nul
face plus crédible intra politique pour
ça pour sauver son groupe et il est
sauvé son groupe et dont 7,7 un homme
d'un cynisme total
keane pour laquelle les valeurs mais
quand strictement rien et pour lesquels
qui est prêt à tout qu'il provoquait un
peut créer son monde avec ses règles et
ses cages voudrais juste qu'on revoie
son clip de campagne de 2006 qui est
quand même assez représentatif de
l'imaginaire
berlusconi
d
face à ces dames
idem des cerveaux
d
m
l'état
car se tourne
un coup là
non
donc ouais la forte qu'à solamente qui
coule au 10 mai
et
bon là on a tout on a une certaine
vision des femmes de la ménagère de
l'italie de l'airé lagdo de la jeunesse
aussi mais on se demande dans quel monde
il le vit silvio berlusconi en fait à ce
moment là certes le pouvoir en fait
donné pouvoir ont exacerbé c'est ces
failles émotionnelle où ils y ont ce
qu'on se pose la question quand même je
trouve
il faut parce que quand on parle de
berlusconi la gauche italienne d'un côté
et aussi les étrangers canalise de
l'osce tony
je pense en cède un petit peu à cette
habitude de analyser quel côté
irrationnel effectivement du
berlusconisme au berlusconi est capable
de susciter d'une condition de valeur
rationnelle très forte
ben je sais qu'il ya des propos qui sont
très claires il dit réduire les impôts
après il n'a jamais réduit les impôts
depuis qu'il est là il a toujours dit il
faut libéraliser effectivement
l'économie libérer l'économie de tous
les les
les empêchements qui sont créées par un
état qui est omniprésente c'est
finalement elle n'a jamais fait non plus
mais son discours est très claire et les
gens qui écoutent son discours peuvent
reconnaître des valeurs de base très
simple qui communique très bien les
problèmes c'est que de l'autre côté de
notre côté de la gauche
on a beaucoup pas fou il n'a pas réussi
un maître de le composer ac34 valeurs
fondamentales berlusconi de valeur de la
même puissance
donc bien sûr il y à une sorte de
phénomène anthropologique des
d'identification de pertes évitées avec
2 sonic comme ça l'était je pense aussi
un petit peu avec shia comment c'était
justement qu'il n'y ait pas eu de leader
en face il ya eu des leaders maladie a
été un leader il a gagné deux fois sur
des fous la faiblesse et les
contradictions d'une gauche qui n'a
jamais été capable de faire une loi
contre les conflits d'intérêts qui qu'un
l'opposition elle pas toujours justement
justement d'un port lan de conflit
d'intérêts est quant à elle la pauvre
elle n'est pas capable de faire cette
loi de l'opposé d'une opposition qui
malheureusement est justement elle dit
que quelle est la position que cette loi
électorale scandaleuse faite par
berlusconi en 2005 est inconcevable et
d'ailleurs les berlusconiens aussi
l'inconnue est ensuite qu'elle a un
gouvernement avec romain rapport de 2006
à 2008
elle n'est pas capable il ya deux
questions que vous posez celle du leader
du centre gauche et effectivement il ya
toujours eu beaucoup de difficulté à
faire émerger un leader au centre gauche
mais là à chaque fois que le centre
gauche parce qu'on y donne on parle de
centre-gauche et pas de bouche c'est à
dire un regroupement de force modérée et
et de la gauche
à chaque fois qu'elle a essayé de jouer
sur le terrain de berlusconi elle a
perdu
ou tu élis et veltroni mais quand elle a
joué exactement l'opposé c'est à dire
mettre romano prodi comme candidat sur
la personne la plus ennuyeuse possible
celle qui vous endort à la télévision
elle a gagné donc c'était très sympa
pour les soldes c'est pas les seules
raisons mais il fallait pas jouer la
carte de silvio berlusconi sur chanter
ça c'est une première réflexion et c'est
vrai que le parti démocrate que
représente notre ami ici on va voir des
primaires pour désigner son secrétaire
donc on va voir s'il ya un nouveau
leader et 6 et matteo renzi le maire de
florence c'est l'héritage de berlusconi
c'est assez évident c'était l'état qui
pissaient y sur le centre gauche de
faire comme berlusconi une fois que
berlusconi sera out de la scène
politique puis à une deuxième question
qui sont ses électeurs italiens mais ça
c'est parce qu'on a des tas d'études
depuis 1994 jusqu'à sur des cas moi je
peux vous le dire il ya plusieurs types
d'électeurs il ya les électeurs des
professions libérales artisans
commerçants petits entrepreneurs pas
tous mais qui représente une forte
composante de l'italie et une forte
composante de l'électorat berlusconien
il ya une deuxième partie de son
électorat un deuxième coeur cible de son
électorat quel électorat du sud de
l'italie qui était un électeur à peu
politisés qui est s'intéresse très peu à
la politique donc avec un faible niveau
d'instruction
avec en particulier à l'intérieur de
cette même catégorie des femmes
ménagères qui passent beaucoup de temps
devant leur télévision et c'est la seule
catégorie sur lequel on voit
effectivement une corrélation entre leur
fréquentation de la télévision et le
vote
et puis il ya une troisième catégorie
qui celle-là s'est vite détaché de
berlusconi ces dernières années c'est
les catholiques pratiquants réguliers
qui était qui flottait berlusconi parce
que l'église faut le dire a soutenu
berlusconi pendant plusieurs jusqu'aux
affaire aux révélations sur sa vie
privée la yamaha composite pardon mais
il ya quand même quelque chose
d'étonnant serre que tout ce qui a
entériné le
déclin a toujours été là dans la victime
dans cette télé ça a été le premier à
mettre des femmes dénudées omniprésente
partout et c'est l'argent il ya toujours
eu d'énormes doutes sur la provenance de
sa fortune les affaires il y avait déjà
eu une perquisition du stade donc tout
ce qui est aujourd'hui reprochés et qui
vaut la chute et qui entraînait une
chute a toujours été là donc comment se
fait-il en fait qu' ils les italiens qui
ont soutenu en fait n'est pas pu
identifier est-ce que c'est aussi une
faute des médias est ce que je me serais
tu viens une chose paraît pas de
commentaire hélas la scène de la femme
avec des scènes totalement nue ne vient
pas du tout les bouche-trous n'y a rien
de notre télévision privée et le nom
mais c'est sans rien enlever à la
bulgare était absolue dans la ville de
devoir de précisions la l'utilisation
scandaleuse du corps de la femme a
caractérisé avec tout
de l'autre côté une certain prude rieurs
et aliens qui justement n'empêche se
présenter la nudité totale est un jeu
qui a rendu beaucoup à berloz secours
nouvelle plats de télévision du commerce
ses talents vulgaire et là sa télévision
a été plusieurs occasions télévision
bulgare pas toujours parce que même dans
l'interview berlusconi il ya eu parfois
des émissions bien fait et très
intéressant faut pas oublier qu'il a
perdu trois fois le pouvoir donc le
la balance a joué dans l'autre sens au
nom et à maman donner à chaque fois
d'ailleurs on croit qu'on croyait que
c'était la fin des trois sets et la fin
dès la première fois et il est dit lui
même qu'il avait hésité puis finalement
non il restait dans l'arène politique
et c'était parti pour vingt ans bon mais
peut-être qu'il ya deux responsabilités
également de l'opposition de son
opposition légale de votre
responsabilité de la gauche
bon merci si berlusconi attire c'est
également parce que la gauche ne tire
pas c'est à dire dans le ce que ni bien
sûr les italiens sont conscients de tout
ce que le sco n'y a fait ils sont
conscients du fait qu'ils soient pas
honnête
ils sont conscients de fait qu'ils
soient pas moralement inattaquable c'est
parce c'est pas ça le problème
célia ont une vision rationnelle ils se
disent finalement d'accord berlusconi on
sait très bien qu'il n'est pas quelqu'un
d'honnête mais est ce que la gauche en
offrent leur politique qui a été fait
jusqu'à présent par gauche est
réellement meilleur que l'autre
finalement on sait pas exactement où on
va aller avec la gauche berlusconi les
choses vont rester plus ou moins comme
comme maintenant dans un pacte entre
l'état et les citoyens qui impacte qui
dit plus ou moins on va être draconien
pour faire payer les impôts à tout ce
qu'on peut choper n'a su que l'on peut
pas choper finalement on n'échappe pas
non plus à d'autres actionnaires votent
pour berlusconi n'est pas un vote et la
fin de berlusconi si enfin elle arrive
n'est pas dû au fait que buck et
maintenant les gens ont pris conscience
du fait que bruce que berlusconi soit
par net
ils ont juste vu depuis vingt ans les
choses vont de pire en pire de l'armée
est incapable de ressouder la maintenant
il va falloir aller de l'avant et je
voudrais qu'on réécoute l'interview de
raphaël et six mois mais vous verrez ce
que nie a eu le mérite et leur a
probablement encore longtemps
le destin politique à la fois
extraordinaire et tragique d'avoir dû
légitimer l'illégalité
lee moore l'immoralité là ils disent pas
le manque de respect des institutions et
des règles catalo un éventail qui dans
les détails
monstrueuse sentiment négatif envers le
bien commun fine tement est négative et
verts seul bnf au moule si bien qu'il
nous faudra des décennies pour digérer
tout ça est un beat je virais d'hespel
il faudra des décennies pour digérer
tout ça alors c'est refait les simone
que je connais bien qu'il a écrit dans
plusieurs livres à une vision totalement
noir 1-2 berlusconi et mais en partie
moi je quitte à être critique ici je
veux dire que les choses sont plus
complexes parce que il ya cet aspect là
dans le berlusconisme est incontestable
et on va le voir encore plus maintenant
parce que comme il a tout perdu
il va sans doute être le candidat
antisystème encore plus il va
radicaliser encore plus ses positions y
compris pour récupérer les votes de
beppe grillo restèrent son comique qui
enfin ces textes comiques qui a fait un
score qui a été le premier parti
politique de l'italie aux dernières
élections
mais il ya un autre aspect aussi du
lobby sioniste qui explique justement
pourquoi des gens sont séparés ces
derniers temps qui est alors on peut
penser que c'est totalement illusoire
que c'est fou mais qui est des gens qui
ont pensé que dans la crise politique
incroyable qu'a connu l'italien il faut
jamais oublier ça les partis politiques
se sont effondrés qui pensaient que
berlusconi certes n'était pas sain qui
ont pas fait un chèque en blanc mais
penser qu'il pouvait apporter un certain
nombre de modifications économie
politique importante en italie et et
c'est ce côté janus de berlusconi lui
même est assez étonnant parce que d'un
côté il ya le cas nous on aime bien en
france insisté sur l'anti politiques
populistes n'ont pas toutes ces
expressions mais le même homme peut
avoir aussi des grands moments où il se
représente comme l'homme d'état quand
françois mitterrand l'a reçue l'a
adoubée d'ailleurs on peut pas
s'empêcher de penser à bernard tapie
lien c'est aussi quelque part cette
proximité aussi avec françois mitterrand
c'était justement c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'il admirait
quelque part chez lui mais oui sans
doute c'était en plus un homme qui
savait faire naître la vision je ferais
tu savais ta décide de créer une chaîne
de télévision 85e' là il donne la
majorité
sedo et dont un entrepreneur pour
socialiste mais il donc à même le 40% de
capital lui permet que berlusconi soit
détenteur de 40% du capital parce qu'il
sait faire de télévision dont il a
certains capacités et c'est un homme
pragmatique comme un poussin et quand
moi je dis un homme qui n'a pas de
valeur
c'est dans ce sens là pour lui ce qui
compte est le résultat selon l'intérêt
de l'initiative de ce point de vue là il
est prêt à emprunter des valeurs de tout
le monde à droite à gauche 7 et tous les
côtés pour arriver au résultat c'est le
cynisme de pragmatisme c'est pour ça
m'aide à ce pragmatisme
il ya aussi des aspects positifs et moi
je suis totalement d'accord avec marc le
juge pas du tout un manoir de la
dédiabolisation total de berlusconi et à
jugement qui n'est pas juste qu'ils ne
correspondent pas à l'année des
réalisations c'est un nombre et aussi en
contradictoires mais aussi à côté d'une
intelligence indiscutable il y a cette
vulgarité parfois insupportables qui est
acquis a été de plus en plus évidente
avec l'âge il y a sur internet je peux
pas la raconter c'est parce que c'est
trop vulgaire peu moins la blague de la
pomme est d'une vulgarité absolue qu'il
a raconté devant de sa élu avec les
rebattre couleurs après une réunion et
c'était une vulgarité d'une
insupportable et tous ces élus cré et a
prôné c'est comme s'il avait donc
choisir absolument génial c'est
intéressant ce rapprochement entre
berlusconi
et tapie parce que c'est assez typique
d'une époque et ce sont des preuves
vraiment les produits des années 90 nous
produit des gagneurs la différence entre
tapie et berlusconi sait que tapie lui
non vous n'avez pas de dande empire
médiatique pour nourrir sa campagne et
nourrir l'imaginaire mais tout de même
tout ça pour dire que ça l'est dans
l'escalier ce n'est pas uniquement une
exception italienne ça aurait pu arriver
ailleurs si le contexte il y avait
contribué
mais là évidemment le contexte
particulier c'est celui qui expliquait
marc lazar c'est-à-dire l'effondrement
géré à un moment donné tout s'écroule en
italie et il y en a un qui émerge alors
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'italie 20 ans que le sco
nisme les les problèmes ne datent pas de
berlusconi c'est aujourd'hui on est
voilà l'italie accuse le coup avec deux
mille milliards de dettes publiques un
coût du travail a augmenté de 12 % de
chômage
quels sont les freins aujourd'hui
politiques et économiques pour que
l'italie repartent
les premières choses si on doit santé
disent aimer les premières choses parce
que là quand on voyait encore quelques
jours enrico letta qui lance un fonds
d'investissement avec vladimir poutine
qui va lire poutine dîner la veille avec
berlusconi a dit et finalement ça n'a
pas vraiment changé
je pense que le principal problème en
italie ce les impôts sont sur le travail
sur la production
il ya des impôts qui sont trop élevés
plus élevé qu'en france d'ailleurs sur
la production et sur le travail et les
impôts par contre sur la propriété qui
sont contre le dans le plus bas en
europe donc il faut la boue premières
mesures que nous proposons plus ou moins
tout le monde est parti démocrate mais
surtout le mont candidate impétueux
atteigant j'en profite
c'est de justement de réduire une fois
pour toutes les impôts sur le travail
est imposée plus
les patrimoines les noms je crois qu'il
ya beaucoup de défis pour l'italie c'est
incontestable un défi politique déjà
changé alberto il faisait allusion
thaler alberto toscano la question de la
loi électorale qui est vraiment
fondamental
il ya quelques réformes
institutionnelles armes écoles les
constitutionnalistes m'explique ce n'est
pas la peine de changer la constitution
milliards il faut trouver il faut
cliquer ici
la proportionnelle alors là actuellement
c'est un système de report chanel avec
une prime majoritaire aux réparties
différemment entre la chambre des
députés et le sénat mais tout le monde
reconnaît que ce système est impossible
la preuve s'il n'y a pas de gouvernement
actuel alors actuellement en italie on a
un système où les italiens vote à la
chambre des députés et au sénat avec un
système trois ports sionnel et une prime
au parti qui arrive en tête voilà que
l'audition de partie
c'est la raison pour laquelle le parti
démocrate le parti de monsieur est
largement majoritaires à la chambre des
députés
mais cette répartition de la prime
majoritaire se fait par région au sénat
et aboutit à une situation
d'ingouvernabilité au sénat puisqu'il
n'ya pas une majorité claire
donc ça tout le monde reconnaît que
cette voie littorale il faut la changer
mais pour le moment
alberto toscano rappeler il n'y arrive
pas deuxièmement il y aura quelques
réformes institutionnelles parce que
évidemment quand vous faites un
changement de loi électorale chaque
parti défend son bifteck et alors les
petits veulent de la proportionnelle
intégrale les gros veulent un système
majoritaire et on n'arrive pas à trouver
un accord donc ça s'est il y a qu'en
france où le président de la république
françois mitterrand décide de faire de
la proportionnelle pour pourrait briser
le front national en 86 mans donc
cela étant dit donc mais donc ça c'est
le premier point il ya des il faut
assurer une gouvernance bilité plus
forte à l'italie est ce qu'il faut
passer par un changement des deux
chambres du système de bicaméralisme
intégral c'est une question qui est
posée mais c'est des lourdes
et puis il ya toutes les questions
économiques d'un pays qui va mal et
notamment alors je le dis parce que le
représentant département crac et d'un
jeune ici la situation dramatique de la
jeunesse italienne les chiffres sont
ahurissants le nombre de nous on en
profite en france on a des tables
italien de talent qui viennent chez nous
bien formés on les récupère dans nos
universités dans les centres de
recherche dans nos entreprises mais
c'est dramatique pour ces pays qui a un
taux de natalité réduit au minimum le
plus bas taux de la perrière maintenant
la jeunesse est un facteur d'espoir pour
pour pour l'italie puisqu'elle elle
s'investit elle s'intéresse certainement
plus que la jeunesse française
aujourd'hui vous le ressentez comme ça à
l'air non je saurais pas dire si là je
vais citer les insurgés c'est plus que
la jeunesse française je serai temps je
serai pas dire bien sûr après il va
falloir les presser les jeunes ont très
peu d'impact sur la politique italienne
parce que la majorité de ceux qui votent
sont pas jeunes déjà oui c'est ça c'est
ça qui me dira si l'italie commence à
gêner riser pendante mais il n'y a pas
de renouveau papa coeur de la politique
dans tous les domaines que les
entreprises séparé
de l'université c'est pareil c'est un
système je rentrais au clic qui s'est
luxé de législatives de février dernier
a vu le plus grand changement au
parlement italien de l'historique les
récents jeux
il me passionnait pas dans le partito
democratico des jeunes la plus haute
présence des femmes de toutes les
solitudes dans le gouvernement actuel il
via par exemple une femme de couleur qui
administre chose inconcevable
délibération a voulu par le prince le
présentisme président d'ekos les seniors
messieurs la relation il ya une bonne
partie de la population qui l'acceptent
il ya ensuite s'exprimer je laisse aux
attaques cristina mais il ya un
changement en cours
et sincèrement je ne suis contre a
acheté un média leurs formes
fondamentales fond de la réforme de
réforme une la réforme de l'état italien
l'état italien n'est pas crédible aux
yeux des citoyens italiens
il faut donner crédibilité à l'italie à
l'état italienne il faut faire en sorte
que le citoyen soit capable de ces
identifications et à celles à la valeur
de valeur et ça n'a pas vu le problème
c'est que l'italie comme beaucoup
d'autres pays d'europe est en crise et
que c'est rarement en période de crise
que l'on prend les décisions les plus
importantes et les sondages nous montre
en italie ce que j'ai pu voir ces
derniers temps que le centre gauche
n'était pas en excellente santé par
rapport à la droite au centre droit
donc on a là une gauche ou un ce centre
gauche au pouvoir qui risquent de s'user
comme si tous les gouvernements
actuellement en europe sous l'effet de
la crise non non c'est certain comme
besson d'optimiste je
enrico letta le taux de croissance est
fixé à 0 7 pour cent pour l'an prochain
vous y croyez je suis pas économiste je
ne sais pas enrico letta est un bon
exemple d'un politique de grande
capacité vraiment européen qui
représente bien son pays qui travaillent
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles et qui donne peut-être un
espoir sur 7 aux deux questions
fondamentales qui le renouvellement de
la classe dirigeante italienne non merci
grand problème est que l'italie assure l
hérault les eaux étaient à en 2011
l'hérault risquer sauter en l'air et la
détermination qu'à même des italiens et
du gouvernement monte avant et des
gouvernants l'être ensuite ont contribué
de façon déterminante à sauver nous
finirons sur ces mots merci à tous
d'être venus sur ce plateau la semaine
prochaine pour trouver benoît duquesne
qui débattra avec ses invités après un
documentaire sur la droite et nicolas
sarkozy
et quant à moi je vous retrouve dans 15
jours pour un débat sur les femmes sdf à
très vite sur public sénat
bon
en fout